what the machine again this comes back
to the machine the corporate machine and
and the people who just suck up to it
whether it is Don Lemon whether it is
Joy Reed or of course whether it is the
brilliant women of the view here is
Sunny Hostin and sunny is as I've
pointed out many times I think she's
probably the worst person on television
maybe it's Joy Reid but Sunny probably
is it uh and you can see she's making
the move here I wanna I wanna tease it a
little bit because I I keep telling you
guys the move that they are going to
make on DeSantis is DeSantis is Trump
but worse so they're going to say Trump
was Hitler but this is Hitler on
steroids because Trump at least was
disorganized and confused and you know
he was a television star and all that
but DeSantis is smart and organized so
he's going to be double Hitler here's
Sunny Hosten what I did admire about
about
um DeSantis is that he finally talked
about climate change right he's like
sort of finally said wow this is a
climate change issue and I think what's
always just disappointed me about
DeSantis is he's a very different
political candidate than let's say a
president Trump I firmly believe that
President Trump is just not the the
smartest guy I really I don't I think
he's educated but I just don't think
he's that smart and
um and I think he's a racist and I think
he's a homophobe and he's a just a
person who was raised that way when you
look at the scientist he graduated from
Yale University he went to Harvard Law
School he earned a commission in the U.S
Navy as a jack officer he was a federal
prosecutor who did what I did was where
he targeted and convicted child
Predators he still serves in the United
States Reserve so what that tells me is
he's brilliant and the cruelty is the
point when he's sending immigrants all
over the place and not taking care of
them and that yeah but I think you've
got to call him as you see him you see
it I mean you can see the move guys
that's why I keep doing this because I
want you to be able to see it so you can
tell your friends that this is exactly
what they're when you hear all these
people well I you know I kind of get it
the walksters are crazy the Democrats or
nuts I just can't vote for Trump and
then overnight they're going to switch
it so that those same exact people will
be saying I can't vote for DeSantis
because he's smart and he's organized
and he knows what he was doing and he
was in the military and all that and of
course everything she said there about
Trump is nonsense I mean she's just just
terrible I don't like you lady